hello everyone and welcome to some uh
extra news regarding the uh well the
events that have shook the Chess World
uh for for the past like a month or so
uh here is the statement on the Hunts
Magnus Affair by none other than Maxim
loogie the the Grand Master the Magnus
Carlson mentioned when he was talking
about Hans Neiman how you know he and
his mentor uh you you know how it goes
uh but this is what he says about um the
entire event and I will put a link to it
in the description below if you prefer
reading but as it's quite short I'm
gonna just read it out to you so he says
in the introduction a grand master and
the chess professional for more than 40
years I have found myself dragged into
the cheating controversy rocking the
Chess World following the release of the
confidential emails by chess.com a
company with a huge financial stake in
supporting the version of events pushed
by Chess World Champion Magnus Carlsen
the first Bolt from the sky came when
Magnus said that I was a mentor to Hans
Neiman a former student of mine with
whom I've kept an occasional touch over
the years insinuating that I helped him
cheat then came calls from reporters
seeking comment on two-year-old emails
between chess.com and me that the
website had agreed in written form to
keep confidential and released without
my consent in a roundabout way the
exchanges could be purported to prop up
claims made by Magnus with whom
chess.com just happened to be
negotiating a huge financial deal so
even though I had completely nothing to
do with the now Infamous match between
Magnus and Hans I am now compelled to
defend myself against completely absurd
and slanderous accusations made against
me here he says something about his
chess career I've been involved in chess
for the vast majority of my life I've
won my first tournament when I was 15. I
won the world junior Championship in
1985 with the highest rated Blitz player
in the world Blitz chess Association in
the period between 1988 1992 and tied
for the first place in the world rapid
champion Championship in 1989 I was also
elected as one of the seven members of
the grand Masters Association board of
directors in 1989 and as President of
the U.S Chess Federation in 1990. more
recently I was chairman of the
association of Chess professionals
helped Garrick as part of and Anatoly
karpov run their bid for feed a
presidency and started an online chess
matching service
chessreach.com to match titled
professionals and chess students in
recent years I have tried to maintain my
Blitz form my official video Bliss
rating dropped from 2731 about 10 years
ago to slightly above 2600 still six
years ago at the end of the sinful cup I
managed to split an informal match of
about 50 bullet games with Magnus cross
and prompt prompting him to master a
compliment you are very strong when the
match was over as a coach I helped Gary
Kasparov in his matches against Anatoly
karpov and years later Anthony carpal in
his rapid tournaments in France and
Russia I was involved with chess.com as
one of their banter Blitz showman and as
a commentator for a number of the their
events and have produced over 30
instructional videos for the website
which it displaced to this day in 2013 I
orchestrated the captain of Infamous
chest cheater Boris La vivano you can
read more about it here as I will put a
link to it in the description below so
you can click on it I also wrote the
book Grand Master insights detailing my
chess career and have recently completed
work on the Queen's Gambit accepted book
for Russell Enterprises in 2015 I found
that chess Max Academy on New York
City's Upper East Side today we operate
three locations um uh Greenwich New
York's upper east and the upper west
side and my students have won more than
20 National Scholastic titles in the
last several years I have played tens of
thousands of games on leeches.com
chasebiz.com playches.com and chess.com
aside from the incidents on which I will
expand below with chess.com I have never
been accused of Foul Play by any other
website or in over the board competition
now here he uh refers to his
relationship with Hans I met Hans during
the world youth championship in South
Africa eight years ago when he was 11. I
started working with him around October
2014 in the short three four months he
went up from 2150 to 23.50 I was not so
much Amazed by his progress as I had
students who demonstrated similar growth
but by his ability to digest the
information I would give him and then
improve on it most of my sessions would
take place between rounds of major
tournaments on the west coast and it was
clear that Hans could take in
information as quickly as a top
Grandmaster could immediately being able
to implement it in a game he played When
Hans moved to Connecticut with his
family I imagined how much work how much
more work we could do together but
unfortunately this was not the B various
family circumstances prevented us from
working together and though I would
always be happy to give him pointers as
we would meet in some Rapid or Bliss
events in the New York area this was no
longer an ongoing relationship when
Hunter became stronger he stronger he
started giving lessons in the
neighborhood of Chess Max Academy which
was located on the upper east side of
Manhattan he would sometimes stop over
for a few minutes to grab a snack play a
Blitz game and then he would be off I
didn't feel he was too serious about his
chess career so I didn't offer to help
him out the change came when he applied
to Harvard University and didn't get in
at that point he made a firm decision to
work extremely hard to become the best
chess player he could be as I never
demanded anything of him and always
supported anything he was doing Hans
reached out and I was happy to ensure
him that if he ever needed any advice or
help or ideas on how to improve in chess
I would be happy to offer them as I
mentioned in my Facebook post about uh
after Hans beat Magnus one of such
suggestions happened over a year ago as
Hans Was preparing for the U.S junior
Championship 2021 I invited Hans to the
chess Max Academy at 110 West 79th
Street in Manhattan and we spent four
hours going over some complex created
end games to improve his endgame
understanding I truly thought this was
his weakest part of the game at the time
and pressed him to do more work on it my
Facebook post does reflected my
Jubilation at the fact that it seemed he
listened to me though post factum as he
played
um as his play at the U.S junior
Championship where he misplayed two end
games which cost him a full point barely
enabled him to win that event more
recently Hans reached out a bit more for
advice on the right coach for him it
took some time but that issue has also
been resolved to maintain the Integrity
of hans's chest preparation I am not a
liberty to disclose the name of this
coach I didn't have anything to do with
hans's success in his game against
Magnus contrary to what Magnus has
insinuated as I don't prepare hunts for
his games this is his own job and
potentially the job of his current coach
since 2014 I have also not given Hans
advice on actual game preparation for
any other tournaments whether online or
over the board as in my opinion only a
full-time coach would have enough
knowledge to be able to do this in a
professional manner now regarding the
Magnus Carlsen accusations Maxim states
that I do consider myself something of a
mentor to Hans though this is clearly a
very tentative title one that is
established at both part participants
will on the Monday before Magnus
referred to me as hans's Mentor I had
what I I have what I believe to be a
friendly chat with a mutual acquaintance
of mine and Magnus clearly this chat
formed the the basis of magnus's claim
it looks like Magnus has been told by
advisors to avoid direct accusations and
work with insinuations he insinuated
that Hans cheated in their game without
saying as much and when it came time to
say something of note he insinuated that
Hans has a mentor myself who is doing a
great job helping him to play well which
the Magnus now is equivalent to cheating
he then came out openly and claimed Hans
has cheated and he will not be playing
in tournaments with him anymore Magnus
magnus's plan is to try to prove guilt
by association if Hans has a mentor who
is a cheat by definition Hans must be a
cheat and therefore he did did cheat in
their game as he looked relaxed or
rather not tense when playing him the
public was then directed to check out my
alleged cheating incidents in 2017 and
2020 on chess.com which would firmly
establish that since I admitted to
violating Fairplay policies of chess.com
I clearly helped or advised Hans that
the only way for him to make progress in
chess is by cheating
now since has by then already admitted
that he has cheated when he was 12 and
16 I would get social media firmly
behind the world uh Champions plan of
further implicating Hans by connecting
one cheat with another there are a
number of problems with this concept
although to cheat with an actual device
you do need and accomplice who has
access to the device with a chess engine
running on it you also need a connection
to the device which given the
precautions taken at many of modern
tournaments especially at the singtel
cup is not even remotely possible none
of the Specialists tasked to find
anything wrong with the actual Carlson
Iman gaming question came up with
anything substantive
pointing to an outside influence in
generating Moves In fact Hans has at
least two occasions during the game
relinquished much of his Advantage gain
in the early opening phase but Magnus
failed failed to capitalize on it
Kenneth Reagan the accepted foremost
authority on the subject presented a
detailed report where he found no
evidence of Hans using an engine and
neither in that particular game nor in
any other over the board game this
hardly gives the Merit to the idea of a
device passing moves the Hunts during
the game and there is no plausible
method known to me or anyone I know
including thousands of social media
posts where I could be acting as an
accomplice the Hunts insinuated a
cheating in his game with Magnus there
is no device there is no actual cheating
and I was in New York City when the game
was played my relationship with Hans is
explained above there is no work done on
tournament or game preparation between
the two of us going on uh now or in the
last eight years except for the four
hour session before the US junior
Championship 2021 focused entirely on
endings managing three physical
academies in Manhattan and Connecticut
as well as a seven school programs and
then online uh online uh school doesn't
give me enough time to work with players
such as Hans and so this possibility is
a non-starter now here uh he touches up
on the chess.com history as that is also
something very important here the email
submitted by chess.com showed that I
indeed violated their fair play
guidelines twice in 2017 in two
tournaments where one of my students in
a class was shouting out moves together
with other students while Consulting
with the engine I realized that the
accusation in 2017 had some truth to
them a few months later only after I
called the student in question cheating
as soon as this happened I immediately
reached out to Danny wrench and admitted
to the breach of fair play guidelines
that I didn't know I had committed until
that moment I admitted this was a
violation though the
uh though the recent videos of Magnus
Carlsen are receiving advice from one of
the top British players David Howell of
course you know which one he's referring
to you can also check it out if you
don't uh to beat a major competitor in a
money tournament on leeches.org seems to
be a larger violation as he willingly
played the move which won the game on
the spot it can be seen clearly in the
video that Magnus didn't take this too
seriously admitting that he was cheating
on the spot in my case I truly had no
reason to believe that I had actually
cheated and was adamant I did not cheat
until I realized what was happening
months later as the thought that kids
rated over 1000 points lower than me
could be helping me play better never
occurred to me I think I was negligent
in not imagining that such a thing could
occur but having apologized for it and
having offered uh to return the prize
money for the event and offered any
wrench did not comment on I think I did
as much as anyone would under the
circumstances now here is an uh email uh
regarding the event on May 10th of 2018
then control for me to start playing in
title Tuesday tournaments by October if
I start streaming this was my reply hey
Danny I'm fine using my current best in
Blitz account so if you could switch it
to my name it would be fine problems in
my groups are not allowing me to compete
in title Tuesdays because of the time
conflict and clearly I'm not going to
repeat what happened with the students
offering a device so until my new
Academy gets off the ground allowing my
personal allowing me at my personal time
I won't be able to compete or stream
during these events hopefully by January
1st 2019 I will be able to play or
otherwise participate in the
professional chess league so that
solution seems most likely if anything
changes in my schedule I can start
playing and streaming the title Tuesday
earlier we can revisit so in 2019 I
resumed playing on chess.com and was
kicked out of a tournament for no
apparent reason here is the email
exchange between me and the Danny wrench
pertaining to that event
so then he says hi Maxine first my
apologies for the delay I wanted to be
sure what happened before respawning
your removal from the tournament was
based on Old information uh for our fair
play team and the action was taken based
on the understanding that a restriction
for you to compete in price events was
still in order I have now confirmed to
my team that your restriction is lifted
and that you are free to compete in
price events once more my apologies for
the inconvenience uh Danny Ranch the
chief chess officer of chess.com there
was another title Tuesday event around
the same time where I started with four
out of four before chess.com server
crashed after wasting two hours
including the waiting time to hear
announcements it was announced that the
afternoon tournament's prizes will be
combined with morning prizes and the
result of this morning uh event are
annulled all this made my participation
in title Tuesday a rare phenomenon as I
simply had too much going on in my life
at the time yet in the spring of 2020 I
decided to play again it should not it
should come as no surprise price that
even if my 40 plus years of
distinguished chess career weren't there
the thought of using engine assistance
given the above history would be
furthest from my mind in the spring of
2020 tournament in the spring 2020
tournament which I played after my
account was fully reinstated three years
after the 2017 events I was kicked out
by chess.com during the ninth round of
the tournament where I had a score of
six and a half out of eight while not
using any outside assistance I was
shocked by this as I was playing the
tournament from my apartment and could
not understand what occurred I was
informed that I was kicked out of uh out
for play fair play guidelines violations
and that given the past history I would
have 72 hours to confess to anything
regarding fair play guideline violations
or my account would be closed
permanently uh this created quite a
dilemma on one hand from my previous
discussions with Danny wrench on the
subject it became quite obvious that he
believes in chess.com methodology more
than in anything else although having
recently studied the materials on the
chess.com website I found I found out
that it turns out that five or six
appeals per month are actually satisfied
and those accounts are reinstated I
simply didn't have the time to deal with
the situation and since I took chess.com
at their word that the email exchange
would continue to be confidential in
private as stated in all of their
correspondence I made the mistake of
agreeing to admitting I used some help
in some of the games in the event the
flip side would be potentially worse
when you are kicked from chess.com
rumors start circulating immediately
that you cheated and therefore were
kicked out remembering the message I got
back in 2017 I decided that it's best to
admit the wrong doing and if they ever
made it and if they ever made this
public I would always be able to prove
that I didn't cheat by simply analyz
using the games in question sadly it has
come down to this since chess.com can
now can now not be trusted with keeping
their promises I will have to do what I
do best analyze chess games my analysis
of the games in question will be at the
bottom of the statement I would also
like to mention that since I confessed
to violating Fairplay guidelines my
account was reinstated by chess.com and
until recently I regularly played using
this account which I agreed with
chess.com would remain anonymous this
account is known by a handful of my
friends as well as my students it is a
titled GM Diamond account and regarding
here he also mentions his battle with
the Russian legal system when my name
was first brought up in this candle a
number of Articles made a point of
mentioning that I was imprisoned for
embezzlement in Russia as further proof
that my character is that of a cheater
this is in reference to my waiting for
trial in Russian holding cell 17 years
ago a deeply painful and damaging time
in my uh and my family's life at the
time some business this Rivals with
close ties to put in government used my
friendship with Derek as part of Who
besides his role in the Chess World was
one of Putin's most vocal critics to
have me arrested and force a sham trial
even with the full force of the Russian
Judicial System working with the
prosecution to keep me detained they
eventually had to equip me when none of
the false evidence could stand up to
scrutiny after I was acquitted Gary sent
his own head of security to make sure I
made it back to Moscow safely that
evening I had dinner with Gary and his
mother before flying back to New York on
the following day so there you have it
that's his statement do what it worked
you will and here is his analysis of the
2020 title Tuesday games I think there
are some 10 games in question
uh or rather now I know it's a title
Tuesday so nine games he analyzed all of
the nine games with commentary so you
can check that out if you yeah if you
are interested with that uh but yeah as
this is uh what everyone's talking about
you uh pretty much any video that is
made online everyone mentions uh both
Hans and and loogie yeah so this is uh I
believe very relevant to the entire
situation and as I would uh hate to
leave you guys without at least some
sort of chess moves uh here I would like
to show you uh okay this could maybe be
more interesting for beginners so
disregard the Liang versus Levon Arena
that's just from the previous uh video
that I made uh but here uh check out a
nice opening crab that you can use if
you ever face the Queen's Gambit
accepted so uh it's a very short uh
short theme and you guys will uh for
those who are maybe new to chess will
realize why it's very strong the keeper
to keep the pawn so after d D4 D5 and C4
white accepts the black except the
challenge D captures on C4 the Queen's
Gavin is is accepted and now E3 you go
after the C4 pawn and now black defends
it with B5 now this isn't the most
correct way to play chess but uh it's
not unlikely that you will see this so
what you will do is to challenge the
pawn with A4 uh so now what can black do
of course if he just captures them the
C4 Pawn Falls and then you're gonna pick
up the A4 pawn and you're just better uh
you can't really defend with A6 because
just characters and the black cannot
recapture The Rookwood hangs so what
black might do is play C6 uh sorry
instead of A6 play C6 and then it will
just capture and after black captures
still happily defending his C4 Pawn you
will just play Queen F3 and here black
will resign so one of the reasons why
unless you really know what you're doing
it is really really hard to keep um uh
that that gambited pawn uh so yeah
that's the the short opening trap hope
you guys enjoyed it and this uh will
update on the on the current events in
the Chess World I'm very interested in
in what you guys uh think uh has your
opinion changed are you are you still
you know very very firm on your
standings uh do comment uh in the well
in the video uh so that's the that's the
news hope you guys enjoyed it and the
opening trip hope you guys enjoyed that
as well I would like to thank red rose
Kerrigan uh David Masa Matthew bandwidth
and Revolution reptiles YouTube for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World and yes
I'm still preparing the shiny Saga it is
it is coming nowhere is there so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and the the
entire article will be the first thing
you see in the description below see you
soon